is colin White who is going to be
talking about case and requesting under
perturbations live Thank You Audra and
thanks to all to the organizers for
organizing this great workshop and
inviting me okay so I'm going to be
talking about k centre clustering under
perturbation resilience this is joint
work with nina belkin and nika hot
blonde so first just a really quick
overview of clustering so clustering is
a very common problem in unsupervised
machine learning and so we're given some
set of elements that could be articles
with different topics and then all these
articles of distances between them the
distances represent how close and
subject they are or how different in
subject they are and then the the
high-level goal is to partition all
these documents into K different
clusters and we hope that the cluster is
kind of a model what the topic is the
values of the group's okay so we're
going to try to minimize the distances
within each cluster and maximize the
distances between each clusters in some
sense so a common way to do this is on
using a using some objective function
some common objectives are comedians
comedian or case center okay now I'm
going to get a bit more specific so in
this talk I'll be discussing one
objective called the case center
objective and for this one imagine that
you're designing a city and you want to
place k fire stations base equally
throughout the city and your goal is to
minimize the maximum travel time you
have to go from any fire truck to any
address in there for any fire station to
any address in the city okay so say we
have all these houses so to be a bit
more specific we're given a set s of n
different elements and some distance
metric between all the points and then
we want to choose K centers from the
point set s and then assign each point
to their closest center and
are going to be the clusters okay and
then the goal is to minimize the maximum
distance any any fire truck has to go
from the fire station to the house so
this is gonna we want to minimize the
maximum radius and that's going to be
the cost function of any clustering okay
so for this example here it's going to
be this is going to be the cost of the
cluster the the maximum distance well
another one other problem i'm going to
be discussing is a slight generalization
of this of this problem called the
asymmetric case centered problem and so
for this we're just going to relax the
condition that d is symmetric so it
might take 10 minutes to go from one
fire station to a house but half an hour
to get back you can imagine rush hour
traffic or one-way streets as where we
might want this assumption in practice
okay so everything else about the
problem is still the same so we we still
have the directed triangle inequality so
the distance from some points p to q is
less than P to R plus R to Q and now we
have to be a bit more careful and how we
define the objective where minimize that
minimizing the distance from the fire
stations to the addresses where the
order matters okay we just have to be
careful that we we keep the were
consistent with how we define the order
as the problem clear to everybody so now
I'm going to talk about what's known
about these problems in the worst case
and then pretty soon I'll get to be on
rights case analysis okay so first of
all these problems are np-hard so we're
shooting for approximation algorithms
and so for symmetric case Center in the
80s Gonzalez showed at two approximation
and it's a there are a couple of two
approximations for this problem there's
the famous farthest first traversal
some other ones and it was also shown
that this is the tight approximation
ratio so this is the best you can do for
symmetric case center unless P equals NP
okay a symmetric case Center on the
other hand is a bit trickier so the
first non-trivial approximation for this
problem was in the 90s by viswanathan
who showed a log star n approximation so
this is kind of a interesting phenomena
because when this result came out
everybody thought oh for sure there must
be a constant factor approximation of
this problem because log star n is such
a bizarre function class but as it
turned out it took 10 more years of
research and some some sophisticated
papers on multigraph hyper graph
coloring with gap hardness of gap
instances but it was actually shown that
this result is actually tight so it's
kind of interesting that log star n is
the natural approximation ratio of this
problem usually we get either constant
approximations or login or something but
just interesting side note is that it's
kind of cool that log star n came out of
a natural problem okay but anyway so
this is what's known in the worst case
for these problems any questions so far
all right so now I'm going to define
perturbation resilience we heard auger I
mentioned this a little bit in the first
talk and then i'm gonna show results
under this perturbation resilience
assumption and how we can be the worst
case for these problems okay so just a
little bit of a background so are a
little bit of a justifying perturbation
resilience so you know sometimes log
star n isn't desirable in practice
because it's not even a constant
approximation and a lot of times these
np-hard instances don't always match up
with what we see in practice
so you know I don't think there are any
cities out there that have the intricate
constructions used in the lower bounds
so even though there are some lower
bounds maybe we don't see them in
practice ok so for perturbation
resilience we kind of heard algorithm
explaining the intuition behind this at
the start of the day but the ideas that
are small changes to the data set to the
distances shouldn't affect the optimal
clustering and we kind of justify that
by saying if if it does affect the
optimal clustering drastically then
maybe clustering isn't the right thing
that maybe we won't get as meaningful a
solution so if you look at the data set
on the Left say this is the optimal
solution but then if we just tweak the
distances by a tiny bit then we get a
completely different clustering so this
would not be perturbation resilience and
you can think if we go back to the
example about the articles and subjects
or topics so maybe like we don't really
know what the topics of these points are
because because they're so close
together that we don't really know what
the right answers whereas on the on the
right all the points are more spread out
so even if we move the distances by a
little bit the topics don't change so
it's kind of a more meaningful solution
ok now I'm going to get a bit more
specific so the formal definition of
perturbation resilience is that so we're
given a clustering instance and we say
that an alpha perturbation is when we're
allowed to stretch out any distances we
want by a factor of alpha and then a
clustering instance satisfies
perturbation resilience if for any of
these alpha perturbations we do the
optimal solution stays the same ok so
just another example on the left all the
points are really close together so this
doesn't satisfy perturbation resilience
whereas on the right the clusters are
more spread out so it's
kind of resilient to these changing the
distances yep also say something about
weakness of the optimum under some
perturbation in there yeah we assume
that there's a unique solution and then
that doesn't change to any perturbations
yep surely what you just said can't be
quite accurate because if you choose
alpha very very small even the left case
it would still be a perturbation
Brazilian oh yeah so and the next slide
I'll get I'll get into exactly what our
goal is for this line of work but you
bring up a good point so if you take
alpha to be one then every single
clustering is perturbation resilient if
you take alpha to be to a hundred it's
like huge amounts of structure they're
very far apart so yep I mean so what's
the rationale behind taking the
multiplicative a yeah to model
measurement errors there will be an
editing perturbation ultimately bigoted
yeah so there there has been work on
additive perturbation resilience to
there's also I think there's been more
work on multiplicative so the way I
think of it as all clustering problems
are kind of invariant to scaling so you
could multiply everything by 2 and it
wouldn't change the optimal clustering
feels kaylee everything into the UN
explodes and then you can talk a good
day to do yeah so I guess if you scale
everything first and then you talk about
at it I guess it makes more sense I to
me personally I can kind of see how
multiplicative as natural just because
the scaling thing but I think I mean
both of them are nice models it's a it's
interesting for either way to define it
I think in the additive model so if you
have an ally this far away then when you
do the normalization within the you
people then basically you get a very
small average cosplay and it seems that
the structure of the problem is like
scaled up our law are you a liar so so
basically need to be careful about how
to do the normalization I remember that
the resolve or additive it's somehow
somehow like depending on the average
cost of the data point efficient
algorithm and the edited perturbation
right I guess they just implied
different types of structure okay any
other questions um so I want to make a
couple more points so one thing is it's
okay for the center's to change under
these perturbations because if we
actually require the center's to not
change it would be much stronger because
if there are just a couple points near
by the Centers then we can kind of under
some perturbations the center's would
change so we just want to make sure the
clusters don't change and then maybe one
other thing I can point out is that um
we actually we don't assume that this
these perturbations we make even up to
satisfy the triangle inequality so in
this talk I'll be discussing
perturbation resilience for any
perturbations even without satisfying
the triangle inequality um can be used
but there's actually recent work that's
able to get around this problem and
everything in this stock applies to that
the new beaker definition of
perturbation resilience any other
questions about the definition
okay so now I'm just going to talk about
what we do in this line of work so this
is going to be a promise condition so
we're given a clustering instance and
we're promised that it satisfies
perturbation resilience so as I
mentioned before for alpha equals 1 this
would not be to not be an assumption at
all but for alpha equals 100 it would
kind of make the problem trivial because
all the clusters are like really spread
out so the goal is how small can we find
can we make alpha and still come up with
interesting results so in particular
we're going to we're going to be
shooting for optimal algorithms so no
more approximation algorithms like the
worst case but our goal is how how weak
of a condition we can we can use and
still get an optimal algorithm so how
small can we make alpha and still get an
optimal algorithm okay so now I'm just
going to talk about some prior work and
perturbation resilience so this was
defined in 2009 by balloon lineal and
they studied max cut and showed root and
perturbation resilience is sufficient to
get an optimal algorithm then a while
see of lemon chef it studied center
based clustering this is a general
definition that includes comedian
k-means and case center as well as it's
kind of a generalization of clustering
and they showed an algorithm for three
perturbation resilience this was later
improved by belkin and leang who showed
that just 1 plus root 2 perturbation
resilience is needed to get an exact
algorithm and then there's been some
more work on macs cut lowering the level
of perturbation resilience and minimum
multi-way cut and then a recent result a
couple months ago lowering the
perturbation resilience needed for
center based clustering once again and
by the way these are all for the
symmetric versions of the problems okay
so for this talk
I'll be discussing exact algorithms for
symmetric and asymmetric k Center under
to perturbation resilience so on the one
hand if we kind of compare these results
so what I'm going to be talking about it
doesn't handle okay median turkey means
but it kind of handles the asymmetric
case and also for the symmetric case as
we'll see you soon it's kind of a more
general result and then we also show a
lower bound for case center so we show
that if you assume anything less than
two perturbation resilience then it's
impossible to get a exact algorithm
unless sent p equals R P so this this
kind of shows that it kind of shows the
exact level of perturbation resilience
needed where the problem switches but
between having a polynomial algorithm or
being np-hard so that's kind of cool and
then one other thing I want to point out
is that this is the first time we're
studying a problem that doesn't even
have a constant factor approximation in
the worst case and it's kind of
interesting that we just assume a
constant level of stability and all of a
sudden we get an optimal algorithm okay
so now I'm going to first talk about
symmetric case center and then get to a
symmetric case center and then briefly
mention the hardness result and I'll
also talk about more robust versions of
perturbation resilience yep that's some
fence in Big Show the approximation
factor and stability motivation
stability should be connected for to be
related for problems like a center
that's a very good question and it leads
to my next slide but ok so for a case
center we actually have a nice theorem
which I'll explain but in general that's
a very good question and we're still
trying to figure out the relation for
problems in general ok so what
for case center we can show that any to
perturbation resilient instance will
give the optimal solution for a two
approximation algorithm and this is
actually the tues here can be replaced
with any number so any for any Alpha
perturbation resilient any Alpha
approximation and will give optimal okay
um and by the way this isn't it true for
general problems like Max cut or even
comedian there's something a bit more
specific about the structure for case
center okay so the proof isn't too bad I
can fit it on a single slide so all
right so we're given some to
perturbation resilient clustering
instance say the optimal radius is our
star and then say we're given some to
approximate solution say the the red
points are the Centers of our two
approximation okay so now what I'm going
to do is construct a to perturbation in
the following way first I'm just going
to multiply every distance in the graph
by a factor of two and then I'm going to
decrease some of the distances down if
they were greater than to our star I'm
going to make them exactly to our star
in particular I'm going to decrease
these distances between a point and its
center in the to approximate solutions
see ok so then what do we know about
this perturbation so first of all it is
a valid to perturbation nothing
decreased because the distances in C
were all at most to our star to begin
with and so this is a valid to
perturbation and now I claim the sea is
actually the optimal solution in this
perturbation i define the way to see
that is that first of all C is cost to
our star because it was originally cost
to our star because it's a two
approximation and then I increased
everything but the distances and see I
decrease back down to exactly to our
star
and then if you think of any other
clustering well it had to be greater
than or equal to R star in the beginning
by definition of our star and then I
increased everything by a factor of two
so now anything else has to be greater
than or equal to 2 our star okay so then
that implies that C is optimal under
this perturbation and then using the
assumption of to perturbation resilience
we can show that SIA to be optimal
originally yeah yeah but actually so I'm
not going to get to it in this talk but
there is very recent work that you
basically take the metric completion of
these perturbations we use in the proof
and with a bit more work you can show it
still works out but this is a recent
work due to makari chevon mikata so this
wasn't the focus so this work ok any
other questions so this settles
symmetric case center so now I'm going
to move to a symmetric case Center for
this one I'm just going to show some
algorithm that gets the optimal solution
for to perturbation resilience ok so I'm
going to start with a bit of intuition
so in the asymmetric case it's kind of
not as nice so by definition we know
that the distances between all the
center's to the points are our star but
the point the distance from the points
back to their centers we have no idea
what those distances could be so maybe
there are some really bad points that
are really far away going from the point
to the center and it turns out these
points are going to give us a lot of
trouble because they can sit really
close to other clusters and make it
really hard to distinguish the different
clusters ok so what would be really nice
if we can kind of find a sub set of
points that exclude these bad points and
so that's going to motivate the
following definition I'm going to define
a set a
and a point is in the set a a point P is
na if for all other points q if the
distance between Q to P is our star then
the distance from P to Q has to also be
our star one thing I should point out
when we're doing these algorithms we can
always assume we know the optimal radius
R star because if you omit if you
remember from a few slides back the our
star value is just some distance between
two of the points and there's only N
squared of them to try so we can we can
just brute force it in the worst case ok
so i define the set that kind of kind of
tries to capture the nice points but you
might have a couple questions right away
like what if the set is empty I mean how
do we know all of our points are very
asymmetric okay so it turns out though
we can prove some nice properties about
the set and the first thing is that we
can show that all optimal centers land
in the set so not only is the set not
empty but we actually get at least one
point per optimal cluster so that's kind
of a really good property to have and
then the other thing we can show okay so
say the blue points are the optimal
centers there might be other points to
the other thing we can show is that for
any point outside the set the distance
or the their closest point inside the
set is in the same optimal cluster okay
so maybe that's a bit hard to parse so
let's look at a picture so if you look
at all the the points outside the settee
the tan points then if you draw an edge
to their closest point in the set a
these edges are all going to be within
optimal clusters so there's not going to
be an edge that spans an optimal cluster
okay I won't have time to prove these
properties but on they these two taken
together actually give us a really nice
property that it kind of reduces our
problem too
finding the optimal clustering in this
in the set of good points a because not
only is there one point per cluster in
this set a but also once we optimally
cluster a we just attach all the rest of
the points to their closest point in a
then we get a clustering over the entire
instance yeah closest points in eight
and that is the distance from the from B
to the point in a or the other way
around yeah the first one so um yeah I
was kind of sweeping that on a rug we
have to be very careful when we define
distances because we're in asymmetric
but yeah you're right closest point
their distance from the not the point
not native to the point a
okay so now i'm going to in the next
couple slides I'll tell you a couple
more useful properties and then i'll
show how these lead us to an optimal
algorithm okay so the first property is
that for any point the distance from
that point to any Center other than its
own is greater than our star so if we
imagine some optimal cluster the
distances from the points outside that
cluster to the center is greater than
our star okay and now the second
property says that for any tube or for
any point the distance from the center
to that point is smaller than the
distance from any point outside the
cluster to that point okay so this
distance is going to be smaller than any
point outside the cluster the distance
from anything outside the cluster at
that point and that's true of all the
points okay so now how how can we use
these properties to get an optimal
algorithm okay so here's the key
observation so what I want to do is take
a ball of radius R star around the
center so from the first property we
know that this ball is actually an
optimal cluster because it contains all
everything in the cluster and nothing
outside but we not only get that we get
something even stronger so the second
property shows this nice separation
property where not only is it the
optimal cluster but everything inside
this fall is closer to the center than
anything outside the ball okay so it
it's this nice separation property i'm
going to call margin okay and now let's
look at what happens for a non center so
let's take the ball of radius R star
around a non center now this probably
doesn't satisfy the nice margin property
because if it contains a point from
another cluster then that point will be
closer to its center
the other center has to be outside of
this ball from the first property so we
kind of use these two properties
together to show it doesn't satisfy
margin and there's one more case if if
we just got lucky on this ball had
nothing from any other clusters then
we'll satisfy margin but that's also
kind of a good case for us okay so the
takeaway from this slide is that if we
take the balls around centers they're
really nice but balls around non centers
are not so nice and we can kind of
detect this so this implies the
algorithm so now I'm going to define the
algorithm it and then on the next slide
all I'll give an idea of why this is
optimal okay so we're going to start by
creating the set a we can do this in
polynomial time if you remember the
definition and then for now let's forget
about the rest of the points and now i'm
going to construct these balls of radius
R star around every point and then I'm
going to prune them in the next two
steps so first of all if if any ball
doesn't satisfy the nice margin property
if there's a point inside the ball
that's closer to a point outside the
bald into the center then just delete
this fall and also if any ball is just a
subset of another ball just delete the
smaller one okay and we're going to do
this for all the balls we have it we
only have a few left and then I'm just
going to add the rest of the points back
to the to the closest to the cluster of
the closest point in the set okay and
then I'm just going to return these sets
okay is that is the algorithm clear to
everyone first ok so now why is why does
this give us the optimal solution okay
so I claimed that after step 4 we have
optimally clustered the set a and the
first part is that if we look at the
balls around the actual centers these
are going to be the optimal clusters and
they're never going to be deleted
because they satisfy the margin property
and then if we look at non centers
either they have points from other
clusters in which case they'll be
deleted in step 3 or they'll just be
subsets of the optimal clusters and
they'll be deleted in step 4 all right
so now we've optimally clustered the say
there's also another case if if if one
non Center just captures this entire
cluster but then it doesn't really
matter which one we choose we both of
them are the optimal clusters okay and
then if you remember from a few slides
back I said that at this point we've
just cluster the entire instance because
now we can just add the points outside a
to their closest close to the cluster of
the closest point inside a so this
completes the proof any questions about
a symmetric case center now I'll just
very briefly talk about a couple other
points in this research so we get a nice
lower bound which shows the level of
perturbation resilience needed as tight
so we show there's no optimal algorithm
for 2 minus epsilon perturbation
resilience unless NP equals RP and the
reduction we use is from dominating set
with a couple extra properties so we
need we need a hardness of dominating
set even if there's at most one solution
so in order to do that we use
a nice result from valiant in Baz arani
which shows a hardness of unique three
set and then we use reductions along the
way that can serve the number of
solutions so that's kind of just a
highlight of the weed yeah RPL p is it
because the reduction is really so the
the valiant vazirani result about how
three set is hard when there's at most
one solution that requires NP equals RP
that's kind of a randomized proof but
then we just like use that result out of
the box and then all our reductions are
are like deterministic so now we kind of
have this nice picture where if we look
at the spectrum from alpha equals one to
infinity we know that there's no
structure at the start but then we kind
of nailed down the point where the
problem switches from having no optimal
solution no optimal algorithm to an
optimal algorithm
alright so now just very briefly i'll
talk about robust stability robust
perturbation resilience so remember the
original definition the optimal clusters
aren't allowed to change it all under
any perturbations so you might think
that's kind of stringent so we have this
new definition from Vulcan and leang
which now we have two parameters to tune
we have the Alpha and we also have an
epsilon and we say that under any Alpha
perturbations the optimal clusters can
change by at most epsilon so they can
change a little bit so in this picture
maybe this is the optimal solution and
then there's some perturbation and maybe
now this is the optimal solution but
only these middle points switch clusters
so the clusters are still almost the
same okay so it turns out in order to
show anything at all you need a lower
bound because if you don't have a lower
bound on the optimal cluster sizes then
the problem is still hard even for any
value of alpha and what we show is the
the very common single linkage algorithm
which is a very simple algorithm the
single linkage algorithm is just you
start with n singleton points and just
Marin every round you merge the two sets
that are the closest together it's kind
of a natural algorithm for clustering
yep the lower bound is just because if
you could completely eliminate one
cluster then also you're trying to
compare our case enter into a k minus
lunch center or k plus 1 senator or is
there more going on to death try to
remember so if you don't assume any
lower bound in the optimal cluster size
you you get an immediate reduction to
just regular clustering i think it's i
think it's like if there's no lower
bound then you can you can kind of place
k minus yeah you can place k minus 1
points spaced out and then just fit an
axe another clustering instance in the
middle and then you just have to solve
that
so we get the single linkage returns the
optimal solution under 3 epsilon
perturbation resilience so we can kind
of think of this epsilon is it can't go
above 1 over K just by the lower bound
in the cluster sizes I think I'm going
to wrap up I won't have time to explain
the intuition behind this okay so now
just to conclude so I showed a
polynomial time algorithm for K center
and asymmetric k Center I showed this is
tight so it's kind of really interesting
from a theoretical standpoint because
it's the first time we looked at a
problem with no constant factor at all
in the worst case and just assuming a
constant level of stability we get an
optimal algorithm and it's also the
first tight result in terms of the level
of stability needed and it's also kind
of cool that in the worst case we have
these two problems that are like
drastically different levels of hardness
one of them there's an easy to
approximation one of them no
approximation to a constant but just
assuming perturbation resilience the
problems become equivalent and
difficulty so it's kind of a cool
feature of this work but then from a
practical side it's maybe not quite as
interesting a result because we we
showed it's hard even for any value of
stability less than two so there's kind
of just a small window of values for
which the problems interesting okay so
now we have the lower bound for case
center but we don't have any lower
bounds 4k media nor camions so it's
still interesting question if if we can
go below alpha equals 2 for those
problems and then also can we apply the
Scimitar izing technique to other
problems ok that's all i wanted to talk
about thank you
and very curious if you look at actual
case entered problems that you might
encounter in practice like the one that
you mentioned at the very beginning to
motivate your talk no far are they from
you know to perturbation resilience yeah
so this is a common question like are
these are these actually our problems in
practice actually a perturbation design
so unfortunately we can't it's empty
hard to check whether a problems
perturbation resilient people have
different opinions about this there's I
guess in this work we kind of motivated
by saying like if it doesn't satisfy
perturbation resilience then it's it's
kind of maybe not the right thing to do
anyway but there's also so I think
there's some nice work about clustering
biological sequences the Opera mention
where they actually do look at where
they do kind of use these algorithms and
practice and show encouraging results
yeah but it I think sometimes if for
like high levels of alpha it's maybe not
seen in practice so much it just
following up on that you know we were
saying that if your problem is in
perturbation resilient then maybe this
isn't the right algorithm to be using
during you're not really asking the
right question you think it really
applies even for perturbation resilience
in that two to three range or is it more
about small perturbation resilience or
really large scale perturbation
resilience yeah so yeah that's why I
think this the results i talked about
our kind of really cool theoretically
but practically maybe not quite as much
because yeah our algorithms are for to
perturbation resilience and there are
other other results for different
assumptions where you can get kind of
closer to like 1.1 perturbations lane
okay yep so let me
even in the range of 122 perturbation
resilience do you think there's hope for
at least a better approximation plan
that's a very nice question and I think
yeah I think that's what could be added
to this line of work so like we have
some hardness results for finding the
optimal but maybe if we just assume low
levels we can get approximations I think
it could be cool to look at these recent
Fox papers on finding Pete asses in
planar graphs or doubling metrics and
seeing if we can do the same thing for
perturbation resilient graphs yep relate
to the lower bound of two full center is
the beauty or a center stability are the
one by shallow yeah yeah um so so we
actually use so they use a they use a
reduction from perfect dominating set I
think dominating set with this added
properties lensing oh so this is more
general it's a stronger result because
on yeah actually I guess there I guess
one of them doesn't dominate the other
but um so their proof works for like k
medianet camions and everything but
Center proximity is a weaker assumption
than perturbation resilience so in one
sense ours a stronger one since there's
any other questions
thanks